[Music]
playing a cop and playing a gangster is
the exact same acting dig that both of
them got a gun they want answers both of
them know if you don't give them the
right answers there'll be a consequence
both of them have this swag about them
that says nothing can mess with me right
so when I'm doing law and order and I'm
interrogating the dude I'm not even in
my mind be thinking like I'm a cop I'm
looking to just do like this
[ __ ] stole some money from me
and I need to know some [ __ ] answers
so being in the mindset of a gangster is
the same same acting sort of inspiration
just to different sides of the coin and
you know believable I mean when we was
hustling if some guy was in the club and
he had too much attitude and too much
like he was so fearless we like at the
top right because for some reason he
just feels like he can't be touched
that's because he's the police dick wolf
gave me my best compliment ever he said
ice-t is the least pain in my ass and
you know why because I have a reference
point to [ __ ] up and everybody needs a
reference point to [ __ ] up my guys are
in Pelican Bay I could be dead I came
close I felt its breath I know what a
bullet in your look how lucky yes I am
so I am NOT gonna be late I'm not
showing up hi I know this is an
opportunity to take care of my family to
stay out of trouble I'm not in trouble
I'm not breaking the law I mean what the
[ __ ]
why would I mess that up